هذه هي مخلفات طائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وقد اغارت في ساعه متاخره من مساء يوم امس
على هذا المنزل نتحدث عن منزلين هنا في
هذه المنطقه في احد احياء بلده بنت جبال
وهذا ما
خلفه العدوان الاسرائيلي من خلال الطائرات
التي تطلق صواريخها باتجاه منازل المدنيين
في ساعه متاخره نحو منتصف الليل كان هنالك
اغاره من طائره مقاتله حربيه اسرائيليه
بصاروخين على هذا المبنى مما ادى الى
استشهاد ثلاثه اشخاص نتحدث عن شقيقين
وزوجه احدهما استشهدوا في هذه في هذا
المنزل تحديدا عندما قامت طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي باطلاق صواريخها يمكن ان نشاهد
حجم الدمار الكبير الذي خلفه خلفته هذه
الغاره في هنا عند هذه ال هذا ال هذه
الحاره في بلده بنت جبيل حيث اقف كان مبنى
مؤلف من طابقين يمكن ان نرى حجم القوه
التدميريه التي تستخدمها اسرائيل في اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه منازل المدنيين هنا في
بلده بنت جبال هذا المشهد الذي تشاهده هنا
يتقرر في عشرات القرى والبلدات
اللبنانيه منذ نحو شهرين حيث تقوم طائرات
الاحتلال باطلاق صواريخها وايضا القذائف
المدفعيه والقنابل الحارقه في اكثر من
موضع وهذا ما كنا نرصده طيله الاسابيع
الماضيه الذي حصل هنا عند منتصف الليل تم
اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه هذا المنزل سارعت
فرق الدفاع المدني المتواجده في هذه
المنطقه في محاوله لانتشال من كان يتواجد
في هذا المنزل نتحدث عن اسره الوالد كان
هنا مع ابنين واضافه الى زوجه ابنه استشهد
على الفور ثلاثه من افراد العائله اما قوه
الانفجار فقد رمت الوالد من احد الشفات
هنا في هذه النقطه الى الخارج ولم يصب
باذى عمليا هذا المشهد هذا الدمار بات
يتكرر يوميا حيث باتت الحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان اشبه بساحه حرب مفتوحه وهذا الامر
يحصل منذ اسابيع نتحدث عن اكثر من شهرين
وعمليات القصف الاسرائيلي تستمر وتخلف كل
هذا الضرر نتحدث عن اكثر من خمسه 20 شهيدا
من المدنيين سقطوا جراء اطلاق الصواريخ من
قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالاضافه
الى سقوط اكثر من 120 شهيدا لحزب الله
الذي عاهم في بيانات طيله الشهرين
الماضيين من خلال العمليات العسكريه التي
كان
ينفذها